hello there welcome to Conan O'Brien
needs a friend I am the aforementioned
Conan O'Brien
I believe in
I believe that they should be a little
more formal joined uh by the erstwhile
um I'm the aforementioned friend buddy
no no you're no friend of mine he needs
you you are an appendage you are a
necessary part in a very large car a
small greasy part but still a park
necessary Matt Gourley and then of
course yes you are necessary without you
the transmission is too late I quit yeah
the car broke down okay all right wait I
just replaced it with a different part
and it's humming along even better than
before
leave me on the road I'm the useless
part no of course not these were all
just just jives Josh's and jokeroos I'm
just kidding with you there Sona you
look good man you're a hair bun and we
describe to The Listener right now it's
really high is it yeah and your headset
is pushed up against it I have coils in
it why do you have coils in there it can
put my hair in a bun without messing up
my curls you know what's fun isn't that
crazy look at that what look at that
there's two of them holding them
together because Lord don't make things
about jokes about like how like greasy
it is and stuff because I don't know are
you gonna do that so much product yeah
they called me greasy doesn't this look
like a Victorian birth control device it
is it does it's a weird spring that's
how my first child was not conceived
you've kept track of all the
children that have not been conceived
over the years for different reasons the
billions and billions of them uh okay
you're taking a lot of metal out of your
hair are you okay yeah
what's happening how do you get through
an airport detector how do you have a
Saturday night special in there yeah you
told me about my hair being up you have
an early printing press in there you can
keep so much stuff in that that thick
hair of yours can conceal so much pain
of iron ore yeah it's just two coils
look a late 50s Japanese robot just came
out Kaiju oh stop it
man ah yeah I got a lot there's a lot in
there there's a lot in there yeah you
you you're willing to talk about hair
being high though yes your two high
errors over here we are I'm a low hair
guy you are yeah I got no body that's
right and I got nobody
oh my God oh God I don't got no friends
do you have friends I actually don't
know if you have friends that asked me
this before yes I have but seriously who
are they what do you mean
I got J-Town yeah I got malarkeyville
Bill Etc
you don't have any friends do you have
Rose do you have like a group we're not
bros you guys don't like we don't fall
in bro class but do you have friends yes
of course I have friends I have great
friends no I but you say that and then
fake names come out and you do jokes to
divert do you really have friends yes
and those aren't fake names they're
nicknames but they're the nicknames of
my best friends that's not that was not
your Bros you're Entourage that's what
Bros do is they give each other a
nickname not these Bros these are um
we're not bros we're just we're yeah
boom companions yes yeah we're just Pals
we're buddies we call each other buddies
hi buddy all right yeah nice do you have
nicknames for your crew uh no I don't do
you yeah what are your nicknames for
your crew one is awful I've been calling
her pissed since we were 12. I remember
this because at your book event she said
hi what's her real name Christina yeah
she kissed from Christina it was amazing
because she said hi I'm Christina you
probably know me as piss
so why do you call her kiss we were 12
and I accidentally said I was gonna say
Chris and I said piss instead and I was
like oh my God that's the funniest thing
I've ever heard and then I just called
her piss forever it's just she saved
under my phone is pissed when my parents
are like I say oh Christina's coming
over they're like pissed I was like yeah
and everyone just knows her is pissed
it's awful I and she has two kids now so
I'm trying to stop calling her piss but
it's uh it's pretty it's stuck yeah it's
solid that's a solid thing that's a good
nickname yeah no it's not good well it's
better than urine yeah that's two
syllables has she ever gone on like a
Loveline radio show connection thing and
go like uh I'd love to send a song out
to Brian would you tell him that piss
loves her she won't refer to herself as
pit she did when I met her that's true
but I think that's because she knows you
know you're meeting her in my content I
was in a bookstore uh yesterday and I
saw sona's book and this is a legitimate
bookstore what the hell I was stunned
and I held up the book and said oh my
God my assistant wrote a book about me
and the woman who runs the bookstore
said are you okay with that
and she thought it was you know like a
mean tell-all and I said yeah it's so
pretty truthful sure but this the woman
who ran the bookstore was really
horrified you're talking about this New
York Times best-selling book uh New York
Times bestseller that's incredible are
you does it anger you that I am a New
York Times bestseller no because because
you got in under a special category what
is the what do you mean immigrant
writing okay
I'm not even an immigrant and that's not
even a category what are you talking
about it is that's what yeah no you
can't make things up to make it make
more sense no I am very proud of you
Sarah you know there's something
legitimately wrong that I no no no you
haven't yet like you will eventually
well first of all uh yes whenever I
decide to write my Tome yeah it'll
immediately rock it to the top of the
charts
if mine did just off of your back I'm
just saying it there's this yeah it's a
very funny book you just and and listen
I do not begrudge you uh any uh any of
your success but but this is ironic
um and it felt like you would approve I
shoplifted the book oh wow yeah yeah and
then the old woman caught me on my way
out so I struck her several times and
ran and now I'm wanted you could never
shoplift I could never beat up an old
woman
tear my head off I went to I swung at
her she ducked and she said
come at me swizzle stick I found this
shoplifting partner more strange than
you beating up a woman I know that was
an old lady yeah